all right we're now live for another dr.
Sadler AMA session it's a hot day here
in the Milwaukee area so I'm all lined
up looks like we have some questions
already here I'm going to remind
everybody that if you're asking
questions that have already been asked a
number of times and answered and many
other AMA is like what do you think
about Jordan Peterson or what do you
think about Slava or Dziedzic or what do
you think about Nick land I'm probably
going to skip over them and take other
people's questions instead and I know
that there's gonna be some people that
are going to be looking at the or
discussing this stuff in the comments as
well so let's hop in
let ramier a scam I going to be present
at stoic on 2019 in Athens if I remember
correctly you participated in the 2018
one would be an additional reason to
participate yeah I was at 2016 2017 and
2018 because they were all convenient
for me to get to but the Athens one no
I'm not going to be going for that one
it's a little bit out of my way and I've
got an extraordinarily busy semester
already lined up so I'll probably wait
for another one to come to the to this
side of the pond or maybe be back in
London again and we will be doing a
stoic on X event here in the Midwest
specifically here in Milwaukee and we're
putting together the groundwork for that
that will happen the week the weekend
after stoical on during stoical week so
if you're really interested in that you
could you could pop out for that as well
all right nassim dr. Sandler I'm an
ex-muslim I would like to know how do
you reconcile between your faith and
Christianity and modern science things
like story of Adam and the theory of
evolution well to begin with it's not
like my faith in Christianity is like
one single nugget here and then you know
science is one big cohesive thing these
are these are concepts these are not
lived
realities people talk about
Jenyns plants those are huge huge
abstractions much of the the you know
you know modern science was actually
developed by people with pretty strong
religious beliefs so if you look into
the history of the development of
science I think that might might help
you out quite a bit just to answer the
general question and you know for me I
believe in part because I've spent lots
and lots of time pondering looking at
examples thinking about what would where
it actually work you don't ever change
your beliefs unless you're kind of a
nutter with one single thing that
happens most people it's a sort of
cumulative process when it comes to
modern science that really doesn't pose
a problem for most of the mainstream
churches I mean you're not going to find
everybody saying that Adam and Eve that
that story is literally true that's more
of a fringe thing we understand that in
some contexts people may feel that all
the Christians around them believe that
you know there were literally seven days
of creation but you know in saying that
they're actually contradicting a great
church father st. Augustine who back in
the fourth century said this is
allegorical you know so I think that's
that's part of the the way that you
reconcile those sorts of things you know
many of the the texts are not meant to
be taken as absolutely literally true at
every point even st. Paul at some point
in the letters says this is an allegory
by the way so you know you you want to
avoid having sort of a crude hermeneutic
of Scripture on the one hand and you
also don't want to you know reify
science there's no such thing as science
with a capital S that's just a construct
in our minds there are sciences which
are disciplines
carrying out myriad different activities
some of which are well structured and
defined some of which are really fudging
things and then you know we have you
know the things like theories of
evolution and you know you want to look
into the background of them some of them
are more plausible some of them are
plausible so all right and you know the
next common Islam is clear about being
taken literally some kinds of Islam are
not all are and there is plenty of
allegorical interpretation within the
history of Islam ap what are your
thoughts on PN psychism pan
experientialism I don't even know a pan
experientialism is people are constantly
coining new isms and I've been kind of
left behind PN psychism the notion that
everything has some sort of an auto put
it exactly some sort of psychic content
some sort of something like
consciousness intentionality I don't
really buy it I think that there are
things that are mere matter and I don't
have any problem with with with that
sort of notion it's it's not you know
most isms that people ask me about I'm
usually gonna say as an ism I'm not I'm
not super interested in it because you
know I'm more of a let's look at the the
texts and see what they actually had to
say not come up with a new movement or
construct or something like that all
right
Zorba I'm reading Russell's history of
philosophy
it covers still twentieth century
philosophy which book do you recommend
or learn 21st century philosophy on a
nutshell there is no such book and as a
matter of fact if you think that you're
getting a fair reading of the history of
philosophy from Russell you are
unfortunately deluded because Russell is
very fun to read but Russell is a
polemical and an often reductionist
writer they're they're you know read
primary texts you know and then you can
figure out some sort of large scale
where everybody fits on your own but
there's so many great things in 21st
century philosophy that you could be
reading I mean there's plenty of blogs
and you know primers and you know here's
the guide to this or that that you could
you could pick up on but I I don't work
with that sort of stuff right although
than generating some content like that
myself why not I don't have time to read
that sort of thing I'm busy shooting
videos and reading primary texts and
teaching classes and giving talks so I'm
not the best person to talk about and to
answer Zorba's other question can you
make a series on post-modernism and its
philosophy anytime somebody can says can
you make a series can you make a video
here's my standard response I'm making
the stuff that I'm making already
primarily for my students in my classes
anybody can Commission me at any time to
make whatever videos they want if they
want to pay the price all right so I'm
not going to like suddenly change my
direction to make a series on this or
put something into the very long long
waiting list that people might have
about can you do this can you do this
can you do this I'm shooting stuff
primarily like today I if you looked at
that board and you could see it it's got
stuff on a gar on it that's because I'm
teaching a class on ethics that starts
tomorrow and I need to put some content
in there some video content that I need
for my students that's where my
attention is tonight I'm going to be
shooting some more material on 9r and
then I get to shoot some material on
Camus for my existentialism class so if
you want me to do something that goes
outside of my already incredibly packed
schedule
you got to Commission me all right let's
see I'm gonna try to skip ahead a little
bit so I get some more other people in
here alloy cipher how did you become so
well-spoken is it a matter of practice
and does studying rhetoric really help
this is an individual thing there is no
like recipe book for doing it much of it
is a matter of practice when you've
taught for 20 years and you have to you
know presents stuff to people and when
you've thought especially not just two
majors teaching philosophy majors that's
easy anybody can do that right
basically they basically run themselves
teaching non majors intro ethics
critical thinking all those kinds of
classes that are much tougher to teach
that will make you a much better speaker
I've never like gone to speech classes
or get-togethers like Toastmasters or
anything like that but I did study
classical rhetoric and it's not to say
that I like you know plot things out in
my head okay what is quintillion or
sister or Aristotle say about this I
just get up and talk right but the the
classic writers do say you know I'm
talking with Aristotle and Cicero they
do say that if you have three things you
should be able to speak you know well in
the sense of being competent about what
you're doing so you you do need to know
some basic things about how to reach an
audience right if you see your audience
getting angry how do you how do you
understand their anger and then you know
as Aristotle says perhaps mollify it in
some way or perhaps increase it you also
do need to know what the hell you're
talking about you know over all right
and then you also need what what's this
roll call's copia that is a number of
things that you can draw upon circle a
well-stocked Treasury in your mind now
you know as a kid I was sitting down and
reading encyclopedias for fun so that
probably contributed to my copia all
right other people might have to do it
in other ways Aristotle also says in the
rhetoric that there's other things that
are needed in order to be a persuasive
speaker not only do you have to be
competent you got to know what you're
talking about
you also need to be at least perceived
by the audience as a decent person
decent in the way that they think of and
you also need to convey to the audience
what he calls you know Mia or goodwill
this sense of you know being being
interested in them as persons looking
out for their interests not just talking
to hear yourself talk but but to provide
something that could be beneficial to
them and Aristotle says if you have
those that that goes a long way towards
it
so that may that may help out as well
Qian Roach I'm really interested in
conservative political philosophy which
philosophers should I start with I don't
know I mean there's there's a lot of
things that get called can
served atavism and they're not all on
the same page so it's not like there's a
you know orderly progression I mean you
could if you want some sort of
overarching work start out with Russell
Kirk and his the conservative mind and
that'll give you some of the people that
we consider conservative it won't look
an awful lot like present-day
conservatives some of the people that
he's going to talk about look like you
know dark enlightenment neo
traditionalists or pick whatever else
you want
because conservative has meant a number
of different things in different places
over time so yeah I mean Kirk wouldn't
be a bad place to start just you know
take take with take everything you've
read with a grain of salt when you're
reading a I'm gonna give you the whole
picture kind of philosopher you you
always want to you know be a little
careful in accepting their their overall
narrative that they're using Qian Rocha
is another question about pop area and
falsification of ism I haven't looked at
popper for twenty years you know we had
to read him in graduate school even back
then it was kind of implausible stuff
and you're like holy crap are these bad
reads of Plato and Hegel you know so I
mean the that's something you can easily
I think Google and find critiques of
poppers theory and of falsification of
ism or verifications or whatever of
these isms you want to write alright
let's see what else we got going here it
just jumped a little bit from anonymous
according to statistics considering
there are more young men not working
staying home with their parents not
going to college and that the second
leading cause of death is suicide I'm
talking about the United States what do
you think could be done through to
revert these trends well I mean I think
that quite a few of those young men
could be making better uses of their
time than spending it watching YouTube
or gaming or bitching and moaning with
each other you know at a certain point
I'm not the saying that we were all
individualist or something like that
but at a certain point
the you know complaining about the
terrible situation doesn't do much good
and that time could be spent working out
developing new skills figuring out you
know there are people like making money
and there are people getting jobs and
true it's much harder to do today than
it used to be in the past and college
costs more and you know we can go on and
on and on but somebody is getting these
jobs and and maybe it's good to look at
who is and how does that work and then
you know you can start developing some
resilience by learning some virtue
ethics and and practicing it so that
that's on the sort of individual side
what can be done about it in a large
respect well I mean I I don't know you
know we could try to create job programs
or something like that but you know
really when it comes down to it other
than in you know completely depressed
rural areas what we're if we if you look
at unemployment rates and you and you
you know for young men hey haworth and
minority communities that is communities
for the most part so you know like do a
big social program that's probably where
we put more of our attention and then
everyone else can kind of come along for
the ride so you know I don't have an
overall solution to that I mean I think
that we're actually headed towards much
bigger crisis and I'm not sure what
we're gonna do when because of
automation ai logistics all these other
things that are going on we find
ourselves with an overall unemployment
rate of anywhere from 25 to 40 percent
I'm not sure what we're gonna do with
all of those people either so I don't
have a particular solution for young you
know young men other than hey you're
probably going to have to take care of
yourself and you're gonna have to find
support networks and support groups that
don't just regurgitate red pill stuff
for you and piss you off more you know
the goal is to be connected with the
rest of the world not in your own little
Enclave and I would say you know realize
that the more time
you're spending on screen unless it's
really good stuff you're probably not
doing yourself favors right all right
Andre gamete Oh any thoughts on
Nietzsche sisters book on his friendship
with Wagner currently reading it I found
it helpful to better understand each his
philosophy I haven't read it I don't pay
much attention to Elisabeth Nietzsche
given you know I've got sort of a bad
taste in my mouth given her rabid
anti-semitism and her tinkering around
with the will to power and her you know
sort of taking care of nature himself
but maybe it's good I don't know you
know you'd have to you'd have to tell me
you know even a stopped clock is correct
twice a day right all right Artie Whitby
Plato said barbarians are subhuman
Aristotle was a barbarian so did Plato
think Aristotle was a subhuman because
he was a barbarian not because plato was
a Aristotle wasn't a barbarian he's a
Macedonian they're not barbarians I mean
this is a non-starter so I'm going to
kind of skip over this I'm lying to you
can you explain the nuance between
attributes and properties absolutely not
because it that's totally dependent on
who's whose scheme you're using I don't
know which philosophy you're referring
to or what you know article or something
like that somebody may have made a
distinction between those I I don't know
you know it's sort of like when people
say what's the difference between ethics
and and morality well it depends on who
you're reading so you're reading Hegel
it means one thing if you're reading you
know this person it means another thing
if you're reading a J here he basically
uses the terms synonymously you can't
you you always have to index these two
what theory or you're talking about all
right
made of clay does the courage to be take
everything into account when dealing
with a person's loss in faith do you
think it's a good book to oh okay you're
talking about the Tillich courage to be
do you think it's a good book to help
someone with this loss in faith I mean
it can't hurt I mean Tillich is about as
anemic of a Christian
as you can get he's part of that you
know you know liberal movement and
Christianity from the early part of the
20th century going on if he was around
today I need probably be one of these
people who's like you know spiritual but
not religious or something like that I
don't know if it's gonna help you it's
very difficult to predict what books are
gonna help what person you know you
might want to read around write read
some Tillich and then read some other
more substantively engaged thinkers if
you want to read other people in the
existentialist spectrum if you're
dealing with a loss of faith you want to
read people who are not just gonna like
you know shove apologetics at you but
rather help you sort of understand
what's going on so you you know somebody
somebody else would be good to read is
Gabriel Marcel or Paul Raque or you know
couldn't hurt to read Kierkegaard you're
at least gonna learn something in
reading him as well all right
shaf ali khan can I explain Kant's
categorical imperative in simple terms I
can distort Kant's categorical
imperative by explaining it in simple
terms sure you know because it's not it
is what it is so I'm sure I'll take a
stab at the first two formulations of it
because the third formulation of the
categorical imperative about the kingdom
of ends that's a little bit trickier and
more controversial
so the first formulation is acti always
on the maxim that you can will to be at
the same time to be a universal law of
nature right so what are what are we
saying there anything that you're
thinking you you want to take as your
rule for action you should imagine what
what the world would be like if you were
to universalize that if it produces some
you know inherent logical contradiction
like the breakdown between truth and
lying or if it leads to a world that
would be a stupid world for you to will
like a world where nobody ever helps
anyone because you might need help then
you shouldn't do that right so your
action you know the maxim cannot be
willed as a universal law meaning you
shouldn't do that sort of thing the
other formulation I think is a little
bit easier to grab
it says you know our act always so as to
treat humanity in yourself and in others
never as a mere means but always as an
end so don't use other people or if you
are in some aspect using them you better
also be treating them as autonomous
beings and benefiting them in some
important way that that respects their
human dignity and another so those are
those are other ways to explain Kant's
categorical imperative
Kyah have you read any Feuerbach yep
right for your Bach
Kyle Wade has a AG Jack question but
I'll take it anyway wondering how you
feel about rejects view that Hegel
endorses a kind of atheist Christianity
is that a Hegelian view you just like
Gigi I can why I don't care about G's
yet quite frankly you know I spent
enough time reading his books back in
the day long before he became he blew up
and became so so you know important
I still like reading his op-ed pieces
his books are a lot of work to get
through and there's all this illusion
you know they would have been I think
better often times with more more focus
I don't I don't get a lot out of going
back and looking at his books but I
haven't you know given him much time
lately because I'm so pressed is is his
view on Hegel endorsing a kind of
atheist Christianity at Hegelian view is
jeca Hegelian then the answer is yes is
it a Hegelian view I mean there's like a
million different kinds of hay galleons
right so you know are you asking is that
Hegel's view are you saying is there
like an orthodox Hegelian view that all
the galleons agreed upon and and you
know Dziedzic would fall outside of it
there isn't any such thing right there's
a lot of different interpretations of
Hegel I think calling Hegel's approach
atheist Christianity is not a bad way to
look at it he's certainly somebody who
is unorthodox in the sense that he
thinks that
God is ultimately the human community
and is sort of like the end point of
this historical development and we're
all kind of parts of that it's
unfortunate all those poor bastards
before us had to die on what they would
call the slaughter bench of history to
get us to this point so yeah all right
Whitby asks if you could say the name of
one philosopher or the next day all law
so that lost works of that philosopher
would be covered in perfect condition
what philosopher would I choose and why
well that's a tough one hmm I mean what
would I have at my disposal that I know
somebody wrote I mean you know I think
for me probably it would be Aristotle
I'd like to see those 143 different
pieces either authored by him or his
students examining the Constitution's of
different Greek and you know related to
the Greek world communities political
communities I think that would be really
quite interest we have one of them
the constitution of Athens we don't have
any of the rest that would really open
up a lot of doors I mean there's a lot
of other possibilities wouldn't it be
cool to have cruciferous and stuff so
we'd know much more about and I'd
actually probably prefer two cruciferous
than Xena
although I don't know Xena would be
pretty good to be nice to have an epic
tea and Epicurus works but but maybe
they're not very good don't really know
so there there's lots and lots and lots
of stuff that would be really great to
have but I think I'd probably say
Aristotle Steven Warren do you agree
with camu that the horrors of the 20th
century were misdirected rebellions
against the absurd if so what is
necessary to stave off misdirected
rebellions against the absurd well come
who doesn't think that all horrors of
the 20th century are misdirected
rebellions against the absurd he doesn't
he doesn't say that in the
the rebel sometimes there's just
opportunistic bastards that have you
know they see other things going on and
they're like yeah I'd like to kill some
people from this this group and steal
their stuff and rape and all of that
it's not always you know it's not always
quite so elaborate as that so what's
necessary to stave off misdirected
rebellions against the absurd that you
know there's no way to compel other
people to not engage in you know react
rebellions against the absurd or what
they feel to be the the absurd or to
direct it properly the most that you can
do is to try to offer good advice and
good models and to do something good
yourself but you know you're not going
to keep this program with these you know
people who are super emotionally
committed to being the you know the new
master race or being you know the voice
of history or pick whatever you want as
you're not going to you're not going to
steer them off their tracks sometimes
other than fighting them I mean you know
if you want to see a good example of
something like this where Camus ends up
more or less giving up and writing to
his interlocutor but writing in an open
letter sense to other people read his
letters to a German friend written
during the occupation and you know the
the you know fighting against the Nazis
and seeing them eventually lose that
there might be a kind of interest in
counterpoint as well
jad asks what was my favorite math class
that I took that's going back a long
ways you know my undergraduate was from
1990 to 1994 my favorite one um you know
we did this this is kind of a sheet
because it was like a seminar and it
wasn't like a subject in mathematics but
we we did have this Advanced Studies
class
where we took Hofstadter's griddle Asher
Bock which was a fairly new book at the
time that's kind of old alright and we
went through it you know chapter by
chapter by chapter I'm like Wednesday
nights or something like that and I
think that was team-taught if I remember
two of the math instructors were
teaching that that was a lot of fun I
really enjoyed that I liked you know I
liked my calculus classes because I like
the theory behind it
discrete math I didn't like quite so
much in part because you you only got
you got to study some cool stuff but you
didn't go very far into it's gonna like
a smorgasbord approach linear algebra
you know I saw the utility of it then
didn't find it a lot of fun what else
they take geometry you know it was okay
complex analysis was pretty cool
province dance I I actually like
province dance because I like the theory
of probability that was that was a lot
of fun all right let's see what we got
next
yeah sonís why does math have to be AA
priori to be necessary when I can't math
be both a posteriori and necessary how
should we understand Mill when he says
that math math is inductive
generalizations and this is falsifiable
I mean how should we understand him you
just articulated it that's what that's
Mills position which is kind of an
outlier in theories of mathematics for
those who don't know Mill thought that
mathematics was not opera or it was it
was an empirical thing I mean he's not
he's not completely out there on that
there there definitely is an
experiential aspect to it I mean that
can shine and his remarks on the
foundations of mathematics is playing
around with well where else does he talk
about this a little bit in philosophical
investigations a little bit in
uncertainty I think if I remember right
but mostly in the that
remarks I mean we could we could say
that we still have to account for why
why there's something necessary about it
and why it seems that we can transplant
it from culture to culture to culture to
culture if we don't want to say in a
sort of Cartesian you know rationalist
style or plate in a style that
mathematics is you know the code
underlying the universe maybe that's
going too far
we do have to be able to account for why
it has a certain you know apodictic City
right so it's been a long time by the
way since I read Mills discussion of
mathematics so I I can't say too much
about that
Riley what do I think about Sigmund
Freud to what degree is he relevant
today - I think philosophers are
interested in and ascribed it more than
they should
well there's a couple different things
there yeah some philosophers seem to
think that Freud I can't everything
figured out or some Freudian dead right
some people are hardcore unions and Jung
is doing something quite different than
Freud but drawing on some stuff you know
there Lacan ian's out there like that
but they're not the LA County and
practicing psychoanalyst because they're
much more pragmatic you know and I think
we have to adopt we have that we have to
adopt a pragmatic attitude towards
psychoanalytic theory we have to say
okay what actually works what
contributes to our understanding of
things and what seems to be kind of
[ __ ] you know and and you know Freud
sort of spinning the wheels of his own
time but really not that helpful for us
in the present and we also have to do
some translation and adaptation because
you know Freud is writing in one
cultural context and we're perhaps
indifference so we don't find them that
many classical hysterics right the way
that Freud was treating we find we find
other things instead I think that
there's some aspects of Freud's theory
that can be quite useful and it's
usually how they get incorporated into
to other things how they get brought
together the psyche the idea that of
deep psychoanalytic
you know digging in announced digging
into our lives to try to find trauma and
you know things like that I don't see
that as a big fundamental problem myself
I actually see that as a great adjunct
if it's done properly to traditional
virtue ethics oh I'm not the only one by
the way should read Leslie cozy acts on
properly being affected about Aristotle
where it suggested that in addition to
Aristotelian virtue ethics we might also
need something like spiritual direction
and also something like depth psychology
and analysis to work hand in hand if we
want to get out of our vices so I think
Freud can be useful for stuff like that
I think there were a lot of people
influenced by Freud who have very
interesting things to say you know so do
you have to like be a Freudian probably
not that that turned out to be quite
quite unproductive there's not a lot of
philosophers I think we're taking Freud
seriously by comparison to say the
middle of the last century but one who
all mentioned was Alistair MacIntyre you
know he wrote a book on the unconscious
when I was in the seminar with him and
nine other seminar attendees it was
focused on rational choice theory and
its origins and in you know sort of a
human and a Hobbesian and Smithian way
of looking at things
Aristotelian tome ISM and then we spent
the rest of time looking at Freud and
Lacan
so you might say why is MacIntyre
interested in those guys because he
thought that they had something valuable
to contribute all right
Yakub pick do I still use wellbutrin no
I haven't used wellbutrin for quite a
while it's been it's been several years
at least I think I stopped using it
before I moved here and that was 2015
I still get depressed occasional
I'm actually too busy much of the time
to feel depressed I've never been busier
in my life than I currently am so that
helps quite a bit and depression you
know has a number of different forms
sometimes chemicals can be quite useful
I think I did find it helpful to have it
as something to prop me up when I was in
my first marriage and I was dealing with
you know working in a maximum-security
prison and then you know while I was
going through a divorce I think it was
it was helpful but you know medication
is always just one part of what you need
to be doing you also have to do
psychological work as well which can be
done in a lot of different ways then you
have to develop support networks and you
have to be engaged with the world so for
me I was able to go off of it I think it
also probably started having less and
less of a effect for me but I I'm not to
say that's not to say that everybody
should let go off their meds or not use
meds they can be quite helpful as a
matter of fact some people use
wellbutrin I don't know if you know this
it's also used under a different label
and colored purple it's it's used to
help people quit smoking so alright
Oh calypso do you know any philosophers
who write in a dialogue form similar to
Plato yeah tons of them cicero augustine
and some lots of dialogue writing
throughout the history of philosophy by
the way you know plato wasn't the only
person who writes Socratic dialogues
Xenophon writes Socratic dialogues and
we know at least a few others from
diogenes laërtius and just the knees i
believe i think you CLE days of mogera
clowner the Megerian school wrote
dialogues I think if I remember right
credo was supposed to have written
dialogues all of which are lost right
but they were viewed as perhaps not by
credo by by some scholars in that time
and we know that Aristotle wrote dial
is lost unfortunately Plutarch has some
some interesting dialogues as well
Plutarch is a plateless by the way so
there's lots of people you just got a
you got to dig around and you'll find
them and you can judge whether they're
up to Plato's standards or not you know
but there's plenty of them out there
David Hume by the way to another another
good example and of course Berkeley
before him
Leibniz wrote a dialogue or two who else
did not you could find him all right
Lord awesome Tony is there any true
morality without a God I mean for me
it's kind of a moot point there is a god
I don't need to worry about some sort of
hypothetical of true morality in the
absence but I don't I don't see it as
simply derived from God I'm not a divine
command theorist so I don't you'd have
to you'd have to dig into that yourself
and decide what you think about it
kali polis can you elaborate on
philosophical irony particularly that of
plato as per Kierkegaard and Hegel do
you think this irony seeps into art and
makes it over thought although so the
last question I'll ask that I think
irony seeps into art and makes it over
thought so over thought not exactly sure
what you mean there does it mean that it
like it's too reflective and it loses
its thread I think sometimes that that
can be the case and Kierkegaard himself
by the way cautions against relying too
much on irony for example in the present
age and in fear and trembling and in
other places when it becomes it just
irony for its own sake and then it loses
its moorings but irony is used in the
Platonic dialogues so a Toro Nia right
Socrates will will downplay his own
accomplishments or he'll say things that
he doesn't really mean in order to draw
the the person he was talking to out
there's a substantive idea or or
intention there it's not just being done
for its own sake it's not being done
because they're bored you know like I
you know people being ironic today right
it's not being done just to protect
oneself either whatever whatever
Strauss may think of Plato's dialogues
it's not just cya right so and you know
it introduces a capacity for saying
multiple things or putting multiple
things in front of us at the same time I
think that's a good thing you know it
does make it possible for there to be
misunderstandings but what you do then
is you think about those those
misunderstandings right and that itself
draws you in Platonic dialogues what's
really cool about them what makes what
makes a dialogue a good dialogue is that
it's not just that you take
philosophical ideas and you have
characters and it's not just that the
characters often represent character
character or logically the positions
that they're taking so through simha
kiss is kind of a dick because he talks
about being a dick and why that's such a
great thing and Glaucon is an upstanding
guy or anything like that or you know
Eric Symmachus is a boring you know
natural scientist giving a boring
lecture about stuff it's not just that
it's that we get drawn into the dialogue
and and it can be done you know it
doesn't have to be a dialogue it could
be Dostoevsky books where like your you
know my favorite of course is the demons
or the possessed I like The Brothers
Karamazov I like notes from the
underground I like crime and punishment
you know I like the idiot but perhaps a
little bit less but I really really like
the possessed and they're you're you're
in the middle of this this back and
forth surged Aeneas fathers and sons by
the way there's another book like that
that well worth reading or it could be
you know it could be within a
philosophical treatise where you see
like Aristotle you know considering
different points of view and every once
in a while making a joke so you know we
get drawn into the work itself and I
don't think that that's over thought so
Diego what do you think of
transgenderism I don't think there is
any such ism
I don't know what that would possibly
mean I know that there's transgendered
people because I have plenty of friends
and colleague and colleagues I should
say and students and family members you
know I come from a massive family so you
know there's there's bound to be
somebody of every sort within it and I
you know here's here's what my view is I
think that it's fortunate that we're in
a time when a lot of the sort of
knee-jerk restrictive fear-based
prejudices that we had say when I was
growing up can be put aside at least in
some places and people can explore who
they think they are and you know what
they what gender they they view
themselves as belonging to it's very
clear that there are some individuals
who you know come to feel very early on
that they are trapped in a body of the
wrong gender and this must have been
going on for generations and generations
and generations and people often had to
just stuff it down so I I look at the
development of tolerance towards that as
a good thing I don't like seeing people
speak for the whole transgender
community as if somehow they're all
exactly the same token so you know any
more than I like see seeing people do
that for for other groups as well and I
think that there's a lot of back and
forth and sorting out that's gonna have
to go on in this time but I'm happy that
we don't live you know in the sort of
situation that I grew up in where I
remember if somebody was even suspected
as being gay now I'm not to mention
transgendered just gay they would be
mercilessly hounded bullied beaten up on
and very very often
nobody would you know authorities would
sometimes encourage it like I remember a
football coach in particular was a real
[ __ ] in that way or they wouldn't do
anything so I think that that's you know
we're at a time where we can start
sorting this out
I don't think that anybody really has a
really clear picture about what what we
ought to do or what the full range is
you know people are coming up with all
sorts of new labels many of which I
think are kind of they are either reduce
to each other or they're just kind of
silly but that's what happens in times
of you know transition not to have to
make a joke of it right transition in
terms of the society about maybe people
who might want to be transitioning so
that's that's pretty much what I have to
say about that saya rasa what is the
place of philosophy in the age of
quantum physics I don't know why being
in the age of quantum physics would have
anything to do with the purpose of
philosophy you know we still have ethics
has that changed because of quantum
physics I mean there are a few people
who are like we now have you know free
will because of quantum physics but
guess what Epicurus was saying stuff
like that you know years and years and
years ago having you know randomness and
at a very low level doesn't actually get
you like free will on a higher level
I don't I don't know what I mean do we
have to take quantum physics into
account is that what the question is
okay then that you know that probably
has a lot more to do with metaphysics
and philosophy of science than it does
with the sort of stuff that I'm
typically doing so I don't know I don't
know what to say
[Music]
Anton can you help me with the konchem
concept of imagination and it's
difference between the first and third
critique I cannot because it's been a
while since I've read either of them so
I'm not gonna even take a stab at it the
a Genizah cynic what is object-oriented
ontology I think that's if I remember
right that's like the same thing
speculative realism it's see you know
it's putting itself out there is like a
new way of doing metaphysics
I haven't read much of it I don't I
don't know enough to say whether it
really is something genuinely new or not
so alright
[Music]
let's see the Aqua pick do I have any
innovative philosophical ideas of my own
where and when could we read them do I
have any innovative philosophical ideas
of my own if I do it's often without
realizing it and I think it happens
fairly rarely I mean I think about
things and sometimes I'll say oh yeah
you know here's the perspective I've
been using and this goes beyond it a
little bit but I I'm not actually if I
do have any innovative new things it's
probably gonna be springboarding off of
somebody else's stuff and it's not
something I'm trying to aim at right now
right now most of what I do is just try
to keep my head afloat with the many
different jobs that I have explaining
other people's ideas to people who may
or may not be interested in them and so
you know I don't I don't really those
those whatever sparks I have of my own
they're they're probably not not getting
to catch any any tinder maybe that'll
change in the future I don't know I mean
if you want to read my work on stuff
it's easy enough to find you Google
Gregory B Sadler and my medium will come
up my rexis to you know educate blog
comes up you know I write in stoicism
today I write in a few other places my
academia.edu is got my my academic
articles if you want to buy my book you
can easily find that online at Amazon so
you know if you think any of that's
innovative then that's good
I I don't I don't think of much of it is
innovative all right Michael ray is it
possible to bring together heidegger's
and Marxist thought I know that was Mark
oozes focus early on but he at the end
of it depends on what you mean by bring
together
if you mean like try to fuse them into a
new synthesis that that one's probably
not going to work there's too many
things that are that are different from
each other between those thinkers but if
you're saying like maybe let's say
you're doing a Marxist analysis of late
capitalism and you think that maybe
bringing in Heidegger
conception of mood and its relationship
to language thrown this pre
understanding articulated as a forum or
Deol's and being in time is useful for
you and you bring that into the analysis
yeah okay
is that is that bringing together Marx
and Heidegger I'd say it is but it's at
a level of particular ideas you know so
all right
Valdemar what do I think of Eastern
Orthodoxy not oriental whole we're not
talking about the Ethiopian or Coptic or
various Syriac churches I mean you know
I think Eastern Orthodoxy has got you
know an interesting intellectual
tradition to it I you know read stuff in
the fill okay yeah and you know their
their hostility to to some of the
Western thinkers I think is sort of a
dogmatic knee-jerk reaction and some
didn't say say the things that they
think that he said neither did Augustine
but you know the smarter thinkers among
them they recognize that and they get
past that you know I've been to some
Eastern Orthodox services you know it's
I mean the the I think there's a problem
these days with the same problem with
with certain interpretations of you know
Catholic practice and doctrine as well
though it's not like we don't have a
problem with this there's a tendency to
get get drawn into a certain kind of you
know looking back towards the past
conservativism that really only shares
certain values and not an overall
Christological perspective so there's a
there's a way in which Eastern Orthodoxy
can be harnessed just as as you know
Roman Catholicism was say in you know
France by people like Charlevoix right
atheist who was like yeah got
the thing to this religious thing to
hold the system together and that
includes this and this and this and this
I think some sometimes that happens in
Russia and Eastern Europe with with some
of the churches as well but but it
doesn't have to be that way and you know
whatever's going on in one particular
church when you look at church history
what's really cool about it is you see
the possibility for renewal and reform
and getting rid of you no matter how bad
it gets there's always some some people
who are like hey let's let's start
fixing this crap right so all right
there's a lot of back and forth here you
know just jumped again nobble Monsour
ass of a red works by ovid sena or
Maimonides yeah we had to read both of
them back in graduate school and I've
read some other abbot son I have a small
interest in him because he ties in with
this tradition of the eight main flavors
or tastes that comes from Aristotle not
totally familiar with Plato recognize
seven Hippocrates recognized six but
Aristotle in on the soul and on the
sense sense in the sensible talks about
eight Theophrastus follows him in this
and Ovid Senna talks about it in terms
of medicine and I haven't gotten to to
reading other than little snippets of it
though but you know sure yeah I mean I
don't have that much time for reading
them and it's really only in terms of my
particular interests but you know I'm
handicapped in that I can't read you
know Arabic for example so I have to be
reliant on other people's translations
all right
so there's a lot of back-and-forth here
let me find a question in here
alright hungry American I'm in North I
plan anymore but what do you think are
some good thing that I can do a
philosophy since I do enjoy reading it
as a hobby that's a good question and
you can certainly apply it to your life
and your relationships and thinking
about whatever job you're going to be
doing and the community that you're
living in and you know you can you can
produce things on philosophy if you want
you know write blog post do a podcast
shoot videos if you want and if they you
know if you enjoy it or they help other
people that's that's cool there's also
plenty of philosophy related events and
groups all over the world you know I'll
give an example of to that that I'm
involved in so one is the Society of
philosophers in America which is devoted
mostly to doing sort of public
philosophy right talking about
philosophy in public ways engaging in
civil discourse and it has local
chapters so like we have a local chapter
here in Milwaukee that hasn't been very
active because we haven't done a very
good job and getting it founded you know
we did a few events but we didn't we
didn't have a lot of consistent
engagement and part cuz all of us are so
busy but we did some workshops and you
know we did some some talks and events
those coincided with like world
philosophy day which is UNESCO holiday
well worth doing I've been more involved
in the stoic fellowship which is a
international organization devoted to
producing and helping to support local
meetups of people who are interested in
stoicism so we have one here in
Milwaukee and here in Wisconsin there's
one in Chicago there's one in Des Moines
Iowa there's one a big one up in
Minnesota there's another one here in
Wisconsin in the Fox Cities
and then you know that's just this
Midwest region there's all sorts of
other ones and you know we hold monthly
meetings and do events and things like
that so I mean if you if you want to get
to
with people and talk about philosophy
there are things like that I'd look on
meetup.com
but you know it kind of depends on where
you are and so there's there's you know
we ask what can you do with philosophy
there's there's a bunch of different
things that you could you could do with
it that way um let's see here looks like
it looks like I missed a few up here
yeah this thing skips around a bit oh
man
all right let's skip let's roll back up
here
so sex didn't need to mean by valuing
truth that then would devalue itself is
an example of the science that threatens
Christianity because science is a truth
and it has theories that trick threatens
religion so I mentioned this earlier
there's no such thing as science there
are sciences there are people doing
science there's no such thing as capital
s science or science and the singular
science is not a truth science would be
an entire penumbra or universe of all
sorts of propositions connected together
in certain ways held to be true right or
at least on a you know held to be
possibly true because you know the
entire process of generating hypotheses
and testing them can't say it's true
until you actually start getting
information for it even then you can't
always say that it's completely 100%
true nature thought that the modern
approach to science that most people had
is just as theological just as faith
based just as irrational concealing
itself between behind rationality as
theology was so you know the
Enlightenment you know you have science
if you want to call it that or
philosophy or whatever ganging up on
religion and pushing it out and saying
oh you're you're full of falsehoods but
these these universe personifying em
they're just is full of crap as the
falsehoods they push it out and they
also applied it to themselves real
scientists should feel a sense that he's
saying that's already in the birth of
tragedy should feel a sense of like
Noah's via confronting the abyss and
realizing how groundless their own
activities are not like they they have
this will to truth but that doesn't mean
that the stuff that they're doing really
is unshakable truth
that's the niche in perspective and and
he thinks that that's part of what
happened in modernity is you know the
value of truth led to its own
dissolution all right
phantom upload what are my favorite
parts from Plato's Republic yeah so that
that's a good question
I'm you know I think it kind of varies
over time right I do like the first book
or at the sparring with racemic is I
think that's fun stuff to go older I do
like the discussions about the memos and
the you know the the class of people
that are associated with them and how
you would need to train them and that
you're gonna find mostly in in books you
know two and three and then solidly in
book four and then you know it's coming
up again in book nine where we're
talking about like different different
desires of the the parts of the soul so
I like that stuff quite a bit there's
some interesting discussions of love in
there and what it is that were motivated
by I mean they're they're the picture of
like the forms and you know the allegory
of the cave that's cool stuff to teach
it pretty routinely I've always found
you know Plato's overall account
problematic you know is the soul a form
can't be a form right because it's
individuated but what's its relation to
the forms and what are what are virtues
are they really forms or not but you
know it's always fun to read
alright I'm ed Hayek what's the
difference between modern logic and
ancient logic well ones in the ancient
times and ones in the modern times I
mean there's there's all sorts of logics
out there right there's an a modern
logic I would say that you know one of
the big differences is that some modern
logics are formalized that means we use
symbols for them but then again
Aristotle did that in the prior and
posterior analytics didn't eh a little
bit you know there's there's a there's a
couple different logics in ancient times
there's wrist Italian logic stoic logic
there's what we know of D odorous the
Megerian school logic by the way also
verges over into dialectic and rhetoric
then there's a lot of different modern
logics so it depends on which one you're
talking about I'd say there's some
interesting new developments but some of
them go back to I mean moral law
is not something radically new the
Stoics and the megarians were we're
working with something like that back
then so Steven Warren what are your
thoughts about interpreting the Jungian
concept of the shadow into Nietzsche's
warning about the shadow of God I you
know I keep bringing this up I would
avoid taking great philosophers and
trying to shoehorn their ideas into
somebody else's scheme I mean there's
lots of people who are super into yarn
and I think some of them like me Chia
but I think that Nietzsche at least in
my view better thinker than Jung is and
I don't know why we would necessarily
want to bring in young stuff and to
Nietzsche to make sense of it so all
right mirin interest in the Frankfurt
School having difficult to read or know
any pointers where to start with the
Frankfurt School yeah don't start with
the Dordogne Adorno is probably the
hardest person to read in the Frankfurt
School Adorno is Hegel level difficulty
you know to read for example in in the
original text to read minimum Oralia you
need to know five languages you need to
know the German that he's writing in and
then you know Greek Latin French English
so you can catch those illusions and I
think there's even some italian phrases
in there as well I think the English
translation probably has it all
translated for you but Adorno is just so
his thinking is so complex it's so hard
to figure out sometimes what relates to
what and how things are going on that's
why my first publication ever was on
Adorno and then I I never published
anything happen after that I tried
writing things but I was never satisfied
with it so we're gonna start with a frog
for at school you know Adorno has a good
book with Horkheimer the dialectic of
enlightenment I check that out I would
also take a look at you know mark ooza
and from both of them are easier to read
than Adorno and then you know you think
about where the Frankfurt School is
going
hamas who is very wordy and very prone
to dropping illusions and kind of
complex too he's still more readable
than normal is still more easy to read
I'll put it that way his work is
sometimes not more readable it's kind of
opaque but you can at least chart out
everything right so that might that
might help a bit Keegan you said before
you're a big dairy to fan during grad
school what are your thoughts on dairy
does glass I read it once didn't enjoy
it most of his middle period stuff I
didn't find valuable I liked his early
stuff I liked some of his later stuff
and that's that's pretty much it all
right
Xerox lon I've talked to prisoners in
the past I'm sure a couple or more of
them were alcoholics or addicts don't
have anything specific to share as
advice to recovering addicts I mean I
guess you could say it's really
important to have a good support network
right people who help you understand
your addiction so they're not just like
down on you like oh you're such a
terrible person you addict but they're
not like enabling you you definitely
don't hang out with your old friends and
go out to the bar you want people who
can and you don't want pollyannish sort
of like oh it's so good you're doing so
good you want people who like are like
oh man yeah you you you just went
through a crisis I see you coming out of
it I mean you probably could have done
better but good job buddy
let's let's find something productive to
do like we're gonna stay away from the
bar and we're gonna go down to the lake
and watch the water and maybe we'll chat
a bit or maybe we won't
you know I'd say finding finding a
support network is quite important and
realizing too that you know if if you if
you are an addict because of your
addiction your personality has come to
be deformed in ways that probably drew
the wrong people in and push the right
people away so when you and people in
your support network get into a conflict
don't automatically assume that the
problem
with them you know just realize you've
got something to work on
I that's I guess that's the best advice
I could give that might be helpful in
some respect here's a tough one from
Caesar Augustus in your opinion what's
the best work in philosophy man I don't
know I mean that sort of like asking you
who's your favorite band I don't know
the best work in philosophy you mean
like one single book that I'd have to
pick I don't know it's tough to find a
single book that's that's that's the
best so I'm gonna have to punt on that
one all right what are my thoughts on GK
Chesterton I like Chesterton I enjoy
reading his stuff he's one of these
people that for whom you know being
involved in in religion and it's good to
remember that he's a convert didn't
solve problems it just made things more
complicated for him I'm always attracted
to thinkers like that there's a big
back-and-forth thing here about
communication Andrew Hoffman is Rainer
Maria Rilke a good example of
existentialism if so how you know
emphasis on concrete experience there's
a religious dimension to his work that's
not an orthodox you know religious take
but really opens up me read the Duino
elegies or read some of his works from
the Book of Hours or read some of his
letters think about his his idea as God
is something that we're building through
our actions and choices very different
than the the church that he was brought
up in as a kid you know he emphasizes
the need to develop your
so as an individual he uses this term
solitude or Ines um kite for that which
ties in very closely with you know
Nietzsche's conception of solitude
Dostoyevsky's notion of individuality
Kierkegaard's notion of individuality
he's really solidly in the curriculum
and you know there's some overlapping
stuff you know he and and Nietzsche
shared Lou solemn a as a friend and she
I'd say she fits in there as well by the
way so you know I think that's I mean
you can watch the videos they've got an
Elka oh wow here's here's a really
interesting question from Jean three
pieces of wisdom I've picked up while
teaching in a classroom okay that's good
one is students may look like they're
not paying attention or they may look
like they're paying attention and that
is not an index of whether they actually
are paying attention or not another
thing is that students are going to have
all sorts of challenges and issues that
they're bringing to the classroom and to
your class and it's very important to
not allow yourself as a professor to be
personally affected or involved with
whatever thing is going on with them but
I don't mean like not being sympathetic
it should be you know empathetic to
what's going on with them but you know
students will will deal with their stuff
in in ways that are often not very
productive and often times not very
respectful to you or to the material
that you're studying and sometimes it is
because they're genuine jerks but
sometimes it's because they're going
through a lot of stuff and they did
terrible time management or there's some
sort of crisis and so you have to be
prepared to help them up and you know be
available but not be getting yourself
emotionally from all
too much the third thing is if you give
students proper support
you know like providing them with
handouts and videos and good class
structure and stuff like that most of
them will take that and and be able to
tackle complex philosophical texts and
they'll get something out of it and
they'll they'll enjoy the class and you
know stay connected with the discipline
later so that those are those are three
things but if you if you screw it up you
know if you just throw them into Plato
and don't give him any help don't be
surprised when they're like this sucks
so alright pensioner which philosophical
text would you find useful the
supplement of CBT therapy against
depression well I would read Rilke and I
would read you know the Stoics you know
Epictetus Seneca Marcus Aurelius I think
it couldn't be bad to to read Gabrielle
Marcel CBT oriented I mean I don't know
that that's a good start made some
Aristotle to Aristotle thinks that we're
we're responsible for our feelings that
we have which is similar to CBT turrets
Cole what's my thoughts on CS Lewis I
like Lewis you know space trilogy I
think is his best work the Narnia stuff
not bad you know he's also a really
interesting medieval history of ideas
guide while worth reading so you know
he's good
Russel is some can I explain the action
against duty in accordance with duty or
from duty well that very simple action
against duty you got a duty you go
against it in accordance with duty or
from duty if it's in accordance with
duty you're doing what you're supposed
to do but you're not doing it because
it's what you're supposed to do you're
doing it because you don't want to be
punished or you want to get a nice
benefit or you want to think of yourself
as a
cool guy or something like that in from
duty means you recognize duty as the
reason why you should do that action you
know you say this is the right thing to
do for its own sake not because I'm
gonna get something out of it ah there's
man somebody wrote just a Greek phrase
here a lot tastes a me whole the
theorems who knows the corruptor of the
young nice did aristotle have a notion
of free will
yes and no aristotle doesn't have a
conception of the will to begin with the
closest thing he has to that is pro and
racists which gets translated as choice
or moral choice or deliberative choice
and it's not quite the same extent as
Epictetus is later used to that term for
asus aristotle does think that we are
self move movers that we do make
decisions voluntarily and and freely so
if you if you could say he's got some
conception of something like free will
Alexander of Aphrodisias in a work
called on fate who's an Aristotelian
commentator he takes on the Stoics and a
few others and he makes an argument for
free will from an Aristotelian
perspective so you can say later steel
the ends do have something like a
conception of a free will Aristotle is
underdetermined in that respect you
could say cynical skeptic what books
would you recommend that delves into
American rugged individualism Hoover was
the one who coined the term but I have a
feeling it comes from the 19th century I
don't know you're looking for books that
are like about America you know saying
you should be a rugged individualist I
think that's something you could
probably find by googling I I don't I
don't know that's not something I've
really looked into
Elijah rights being a student of
political science for my BA I want to
study philosophy is that my MA but my
teacher suggested me to keep track with
political science do you think I should
listen to them I don't know I don't know
your situation I don't know your
teachers they might be really smart
people they might be really dumb people
I don't know you oh you know that's
that's you're placing me in sort of a
surgery in position where I don't know I
don't have a good answer to that right
you have to decide for yourself all
right we've got about 15 minutes left
I'm going to start picking up on some
some other things here Martin asks our
counts observations on math affected in
any way by the developments in
foundations of math and logic I don't
know that many mathematicians that take
hot very seriously so maybe but it's not
something I spent a lot of time on you
know gene asks you says you should do
more personal videos you did your
bookshelf tour there wasn't much poetry
on it three favorite poets thoughts on
American poet Charles Bukowski
I don't like Bukowski because most of
the people that I've known that we're
into Bukowski were jerks he was really
really really popular when I was in
college and graduate school and people
would basically you know they try to be
Bukowski right drink a lot smoke a lot
you know get in fights and screw a lot I
mean there's another guy earlier than
him Norman Mailer same kind of deal
right I've never found that really that
attractive
I mean Rilke is definitely my favorite
poet top you know person I'll say that
my wife really likes Szymborska and I'm
starting to warm up to her and
I am Lehrer in terms of like lyric
allottee and stuff like that I like bold
layer I don't read much poetry I don't
get much time to do that
unfortunately I mean a good bit of the
poetry that I do read will be like epic
stuff but I'm not reading it in you know
unless I'm reading in the original which
is pretty rare not reading it in poetic
form so alright
I was really what do you think of Rawls
as a philosopher but also as a reader of
modern philosophers such as Hobbes I've
seen some videos where you've been quite
critical of analytic philosophers so
let's say it's begin an analytic
philosophy huge spectrum there's not one
single thing that's analytic philosophy
Rawls is a ok reader of history of
philosophy he doesn't aim to be faithful
as most analytics don't to the people
that he's reading he's aiming to mine
them for ideas and you know he's ok on
that I'd say that Rawls is better off
than a lot of analytic philosophers and
that he actually like reads full texts
which which is to his credit and then
when he does that he's better there's
other people like random who are you
know officially analytics but are
basically good history of philosophy or
continental people Rawls is interesting
I think that Rawls basically took a sort
of Harvard you know liberal point of
view from the 1960s very provincial but
presenting itself as universal and then
blew it up into something that caught
the attention of a lot of people again
probably you know large part because
he's from Harvard you know prestige
plays a major role in the philosophical
establishment
I mean his works are interesting they're
worth reading I teach some of his stuff
but I don't you know if you're gonna say
like who are the you know top 10 great
philosophers he would be in it so all
right let's see here Andrew is the
philosophy of melancholy any comparison
to modern
philosophy on depression I'd say there's
continuity between the two I don't know
what you mean by philosophy of
melancholy you're talking about like you
know some some particular strain running
through the history of philosophy so I
don't know I know that people are still
discussing it christina has a whole book
on melancholia so Forest Rumble what
text would be best whether primary
secondary for an undergraduates
introduction of phenomenology would
William James be a good start despite
being in the American tradition no I
would say you know you probably want
something by his role right so maybe
Cartesian meditations would be good
Don ID has a nice introduction of
phenomenology out there there's a you
know overviews of the phenomenological
movement sailors rose on to mount book
pretty very accessible
he's a phenomenologist who else
I mean marsala's doing phenomenology a
lot of his stuff is quite readable so
yeah I guess that's what I would suggest
but it's not something I think much
about pop us when Nietzsche said god is
dead did he see it as something
liberating or was he worried that god is
dead does it takes purpose away from us
and takes away structure of ethics both
yeah both of them it does open up new
opportunities for us but we have an
incredible challenge in front of us that
we have to deal with if he's correct if
Neil ISM really is the problem of the
century to come which for him is the
20th century ahead of him and which for
us is the 20th century behind us but
still continuing on all right let's see
here Charles Baudelaire did you ever
study cybernetics
I studied stuff that verged into
cybernetics and used the term but I
wouldn't say was any sort of in-depth
study of it so yeah cribbage do you
think Audrey Burke Sloane is a good
philosopher worth reading yeah he is a
good
for worth reading I would say that if
you were going to read him you want to
start with the early work the essay on
the immediate Givens of consciousness
which i think is translated as time and
freewill
his book on laughter is quite good and
then of course there's the two sources
of morality and religion which is a good
book I may actually start using that in
some of my ethics classes if I have had
the time so he was worth checking out he
got kind of left behind right but he and
Maurice blown-down and Gabrielle Marcel
were really responsible for the
revitalization of metaphysics in France
in in the early 20th century and for the
French reception of phenomenology if it
hadn't been for for those guys I don't
think that that phenomenology would have
been able to make the the inroads that
it did Andrew Huffman what's your
philosophy on AI I don't have a
philosophy yeah you know I think you
know you give me too much credit to
think that I have a whole philosophy on
something as I was saying I don't have
an awful lot of original thoughts you
know all right oh yes if you read Marx's
capital how hard did you find it to read
and what age do you read it started
reading it in graduate school never made
it all the way through capital volume
one so I found it hard to read but you
know not impossible so good to go
through whoa can you speak to
misunderstandings in classical
philosophy particularly Aristotle arose
from the Latin tradition and their
translations instead of the original
dream yeah
not most of the people that talk about
these misunderstandings are full of crap
that's what I'll say
especially Heidegger you know just read
some Cicero Cicero new Greek put the
stuff into Latin the people who were
translating we're not dummies but we
theists by the way had this project of
translating Oliveira Saad on all Plato's
works into Latin and unfortunately he
died young people make way too much of
this
and it's been way overblown most of the
people who could read you know who are
putting the stuff into Latin they know
Greek they they discussed whether this
is a good translation or a bad
translation it's it's sort of a
linguistic one upmanship you know we
Germans are like the ancient Greeks and
we know our terms are similar not like
those damn Latins you know who in the
Middle Ages carried on the tradition and
got everything all garbled up they
translated you know logos as ROTC all oh
my god well I mean that that's that's
kind of a that's a story but it's it's
not a real true story so you know I
would I would take a lot of that with a
grain of salt
Martin Costa are you familiar with the
ecological rationality project general
thoughts on decision theory and
rationality I'm not familiar with that
project decision theory and rationality
is very nice for very clearly defined
problems it's a nightmare
when people think that that's how people
actually do behave and make decisions
and it can't it can't deal with you know
the things that we needed to deal with
and I can't take it into account its own
problems
so yeah let's see here I'm so sorry
about this Tiger killed Jayhawk I'm a
music composition student surrounded by
terrible a tonal music what do I say to
a professor who says that five people
popping bubble wrap is good music any
text on aesthetics I should read I'm not
an aesthetician so I I don't really have
much to say about that
I will say hi commiserate with you I
mean when it comes down to it and
graduate school it doesn't pay and I'm
somebody who actually did did you know
do this an awful lot it doesn't really
pay to argue with your professors and
try to prove them wrong they've got
their positions they're invested in it
learn what you can from them you know
think privately on your own this guy's
full of crap
but I can learn something from them
you're not going to change their minds
though the key is to keep yourself sane
and to learn the stuff that you feel
you're not getting so figure out where
you're gonna so like you know I knew
that the people at SIU when I was going
there were not very good when it came to
you know ancient and medieval philosophy
so I did my medieval on my own you know
I learned Latin and and studied Ansem
and Aquinas and you know whoever else I
wanted to look at and I did my my
Aristotle and Plato in the classics
departments that have been the
philosophy department you know sometimes
that'll be what you have to do is find
other places to get the the information
that you want but I do and you
sympathize with you because man that
would suck all right let's see here
Sabir as a two-part question on stoicism
what would be the most important ideas
on which Epictetus Marcus Seneca
something or other and then who would be
a stoic in recent history - stood up for
the principles of stoicism there's a
whole modern stoic movement out there so
you got down the Robertson Massimo
Pigliucci you got Lawrence Becker
there's there's plenty of people out
there Margaret graver you just got that
you just got a Google search right or go
to you know go and look at see who's
talking at stoic on right look at the
past of things just type in stoic on two
thousand sixteen seventeen eighteen see
who's out there doing stuff will be the
most important ideas in epictetus Marcus
or Seneca there's there's a whole range
of them Seneca tells you stoicism is a
complex systematic philosophy so you
know the idea some people try to say
well it's all about the dichotomy of
control or it's all about you know
virtue is the only good well those are
ideas that are important within it but
they're not the only ideas so you want
to look at the totality and you know I
would get yourself Epictetus as
discourses and Senecas letters and start
reading through them and you're gonna
you're gonna see which ideas keep
popping out at you alright ah let's see
here
testing channel does Socrates think that
piety is part of virtue or the whole of
virtue neither he thinks it's a he
thinks it's a a virtue right and if we
want to say that virtue has parts which
he never fully commits himself to that's
that's quite fine piety never really
gets clarified in the Platonic texts it
might be a variant of Justice it might
be a fifth virtue of its own Plato
doesn't actually stake out a coherent
position on that
sailor Venice what's the best way to
learn about Hegel without having to read
Hegel oh hell would I know I mean
what's the best way to like you know
find out what the ocean is like without
ever going near the ocean read Hegel I
mean if you want to read Hegel read
Hegel if you don't want to read Hegel
don't read Hegel get whatever secondary
text you want understand that since you
haven't actually read the agel you have
no idea whether they're full of crap or
not and you know whether they've got
their own you know weird take if you
want to understand Hegel you go to
somewhere down the line read Hegel J to
Nick to the ancient Hellenic
philosophers hold that distinction
necessitates division no we can
distinguish things without them being
divided Aristotle talks about that and
on the soul you know there's lots of
ways to distinguish parts of the soul
and you know not all of them are
actually parts that are separate from
each other let's see here oh about two
minutes left I gotta get to work pretty
soon let's see what I can grab on to
very quickly
oops I just skipped again oh here's a
good thing to go out on how relevant is
modern philosophy some people are in the
opinion that it's no longer pertinent
due to its quote lack of answers it's
got lots of answers anybody who thinks
there's a lack just isn't doing any work
but the problem is is that there's a
variety of answers and the question is
which is the answer and it's best to
understand that you know very very many
fields suffer from that that same sort
of problem including all of the social
sciences including all of the humanities
including you know actually
quite a few other things as well anybody
who tries to say that there's the
answers in business the answers and
engineering are lying to you or ignorant
so that's that's not really an issue
that the problem is is learning how to
distinguish better answers from worse
answers and how to put together
something that can actually make sense
out of the world for you so that's you
know that takes a good bit of work but I
would I would just ignore those people
they don't know what they're talking
about you know oftentimes they're
they're criticizing something that they
got presented to themselves as
philosophy by somebody who was a bad
teacher and or they you know they read
some textbook somewhere or they read you
know some wiki articles but they they
haven't really explored it so don't let
that discourage you
philosophy is relevant and it's not just
modern philosophy ancient medieval
modern late modern philosophy you can
read people and get something out of
them you can find plenty of stuff in
Cicero that can inform your life today
but you have to be willing to you know
put in the work to find it and you know
to more additional work to to think
about how you would actually apply it
then see what works it's not something
where you're given like a cookie cutter
that you can just like plop down and and
do it it's more of a dialogical
interaction with reality mediated by
somebody who gives you some ideas that
might be helpful so great place to end
didn't get to everybody but I got to
quite a few questions thanks everybody
who came and watched and asked questions
we'll be doing a philosophy pop up both
here and in YouTube later on this month
similar sort of thing I'll announce it
on the day and of course we do these
every single month you just got to go to
my reason il calendar or to my Facebook
page and you see the dates for them well
in advance or if you're a patreon
supporter generally I announce them
ahead of time I think I forgot to do
this month long I've been super super
busy so right I'm gonna say goodbye to
everybody and have a great day
or evening or night or whatever it is
where you happen to be so I'll see all
of you some other time